It
's not the floor of Mr. Tani yet. It's not difficult to get the trials in each sea. It's
not difficult. You can turn on the power to move the elevator in the prison.
[Music]
There is a 10% reduction in such a place.
This is Kathy's favorite and has more gimmicks than anywhere else.
She
was good at using it to guide people to seek heartfelt disclosure and relief,
just a little
wasted.
Let's say it's charming.
Those who are looking for publicity and relief when Kathy disappears
may be saying the floor around the time.
[Applause]
Let's start the trial
bt bt
Rachel Gardner If you do
n't hurry
[Music] Hmm
.
[Music]
Yeah yeah yeah [Music] Oh
Yamada
[Music]
dea
me
There's no corpse There's no corpse
If you don't
mind us
this morning's giant
[Music]
Don't disturb me